Kim O’Hara, Author/Book Coach/Speaker/Podcaster:
This is a beautiful book. We've done a great job
but who cares and he looked at me and he went
"What do you mean who cares?" and " said "How
are we going make this something that stands
out amid all the other people that thought
that they should write a memoir?"
because he's not famous...
Film Courage: What are some common mistakes
you see new writers make that once they're at a
professional level you don't see as much? Kim: So
what would so professional levels an interesting
term because what would that be I mean I i say to
um my clients the minute you've made a decision to
write a book you are now a professional author and
you need to think that way and if you have to take
a post-it and you have to put it on your desk that
says I am a professional author or I am an author
you need to do that you need to put it everywhere
in your house until you actually believe that you
are of the same quality as anybody else
there's no like distinction between you
and the person who's super famous or as a new york
times bestseller you have to own that within you
first and I think once they step to that then
it's really just it's time to work on the craft
and there's certain writers that take to
this the art of writing like a duck to water
they will take direction really quickly they'll
you know they're not afraid of us doing a first
draft and then me saying okay let's rip it apart
because the middle of the book should be where we
start the book and this see this chapter should
mix with this chapter and I think we might need
a different ending because that's what happens
when you do the first draft the second draft is
really where the magic happens there are
some people that are not afraid of that
they're like let's they roll up there let's let's
do it and there's other people that are like
oh my god what does that mean like we just I
just did this for like 12 weeks now you're going
we're going rip it apart what is that and
there's a lot more fear of the process right
which is understandable because they just did
a process that they were not comfortable with
they just they're like oh phew I just got through
that and now we have oh there's another process
but inevitably everybody at the end of the second
draft sees the light at the end of the tunnel
no matter where they were in the first draft
they're all like this is good some are more like
a little bit like we're on to something and other
other people are like oh my god this is like
so excited like this is magic like magic has
happened so I think by the end of the second
draft they all kind of feel like professional
writers some of them might hang on a little bit to
uh they might start to as it gets closer to like
going out and looking for a publisher well do you
think my writing's good like are you sure it's up
to standard do you think my writing is good enough
and you know it's just assurance it's like
it's not that you're right it's not whether
your writing is right or wrong it's are you
communicating in a clear entertaining and
effective way something that's going to inspire
the reader and drive them to take some kind of
action in their life right like uh maybe
you're you're you're espousing some kind
of new philosophy have you done a good enough job
having them actually sit up and go I never thought
about that I’m going change the way I do that in
my life which is what a lot of great books will do
why would someone be afraid to go through the
first draft whereas others are like yeah let's
do it rip it apart like tell me the truth I think
just that that there's that there is a banality
even there's like a conflict right so on one hand
they've been told for years by everybody under the
sun you should write a book and so they believe
and then there's underneath a little part of them
that believes that right but they're coming in
a little bit driven on external forces right so
they'll come in and they'll be like okay well
I'm going do it kind of because everybody else
said I should do it and I kind of believe I
should do it so I’m going to write this thing
but there's in the back of their mind still
that like self-defeating mindset that's like
and it's often can be a voice that
says who cares does this really matter
like you're spending all this time and energy
like putting this out because what the valet
said you should write a story because your
aunt Mary said you should write a story
I don't know this seems like a lot of time and
a lot of you're spending a lot of time with that
Kim lady how do you even know she's qualified
like what even are her credentials and I joke
about this sometimes when I do talks about what
that voice will do to try to keep you safe right
because you've been safe you've gotten so far
your ego's like we're cool we're good and all of
a sudden you're like but I actually want to tell
them that he goes like no wait a minute we've been
good without you telling all these stories
why do you want to upset the apple cart now
so that's more what I see coming into play
and it comes in all different ways it comes in
tears it comes in argumentativeness it comes in
you know I see it all I have a lot of very strong
willed personality clients and I see
it come out in all different ways.
What about a third draft oh the third draft is
just heaven because we've ripped it apart we've
put it back together we know exactly what the
book is and now we get to do like a lot of bells
and whistles so um maybe we didn't find a system
in the book that we knew would have to be there
I used my client Allen F. Maxwell a lot for this
example he had written a a memoir about his life
from Philadelphia to becoming a top defense
contractor in San Diego in the Navy in between
and we were done with the third draft and I
said we've done a beautiful book we've done
a beautiful job this is someone who knew nothing
about writing and dictated most of his book and
we had to like do a lot of fixing on it but
got it done in the airport on a busy schedule
and I said this is a beautiful book we've done a
great job but who cares and he looked at me and
he went what do you mean who cares and I said how
are we going make this something that stands out
amid all the other people that thought that they
should write a memoir because he's not famous
and I said every time you write something
you talk about a system that you've been
in whether it's various parts of the Navy or parts
of society in Georgia or the government and I said
you've got some rules that you've applied in
your life to get through those situations that
you've then carried into new situations how
many do you think you might have of those
rules he said I don't know let me go let me
go figure it out so we came up with 15 rules
we then went back through the book on a fourth
draft found all the places the rules would apply
and put them into the book and he became
a wall street journal top 10 business book
wow so we went from great this is your life it
very interesting but who are you and why should we
be dialed in to then you tapped into that a lot
of rules structures things in place interesting
yeah and we made it something that was for
anybody like we had a 17 year old girl read
it and she was just blown away yeah she was like
I would take this as my book that I would bring
out into the world and use because if you
think about it anytime we step into anywhere
if you have these tips that he gives
and you understand these rules apply
and you're savvy with them you can figure
out who your allies are who your enemies are
you know you can figure out you can keep your eyes
open and attuned to certain certain situations
see the red flags you're going to do pretty well
interesting so was it was it too vanilla before
or it was still interesting but he wasn't giving
the reader anything exactly okay and so is that
something that could be as we all think our lives
are fascinating and okay they won't make a movie
about me but maybe if I write my book they'll
they'll right right but but is is that what
sometimes we're missing is what are we offering
the reader what are we offering the reader and he
actually has some discreet chapters that are
standalone movies without a doubt I mean he has
you know USS destroyers getting song I mean he
has very exciting moments but that wasn't enough
right it's great to read that that adds to
his credibility with his knowledge that he's
sharing but standalone it wasn't a hundred
percent enough um when people come to me
write memoirs I do say what do you think
are your like core areas that you have
the the golden thread or the line of something
your whole life you've kind of not paid attention
to so it might be money messaging from childhood
and then money chaos money chaos money chaos money
chaos till finally they changed something and now
they might not still be great with money but they
they're free right and then all the scenes support
that through line someone could read that and see
their money stories and see their pattern and
so it's like they they they are able to have
like some kind of epiphany a recovery or learning
curve through being entertained in that narrative.
Question For The Viewers: What
did you like about this video?